[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen ihnen allen Katja Stresow ist
auch dabei mit viel Wintersport und der
Fußball-Bundesliga schönen guten Abend
schauen wir auf die Nachrichten Themen
von heute
Kanzler Scholz in Indien Besuch bei
einem wichtigen aber auch schwierigen
Partner vor allem wegen dessen Nähe zu
Russland
Friedenskundgebung in Berlin mehr als
10.000 Demonstranten folgen dem
umstrittenen Aufruf von Sahra
Wagenknecht und Alice Schwarzer
und Freudentanz bei den Deutschen
Skispringerinnen sie gewinnen bei der WM
in slowenischen Planitzer Gold im
Teamspringen
es geht um viel bei der Indien-Reise des
Bundeskanzlers Deutschland möchte die
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen vertiefen braucht
indische Fachkräfte und will das Indien
den russischen Angriffskrieg verurteilt
Indien aber möchte neutral bleiben und
enthielt sich als die unvollversammlung
diese Woche über einen Rückzug Russlands
abstimmte indien hat seine Geschäfte mit
Moskau sogar noch ausgebaut es ist
Hauptabnehmer für russisches Öl und es
bezieht den Großteil seiner
Rüstungsgüter aus Russland Normen
Odenthal über eine schwierige Mission
das Wort Freundschaft fällt heute häufig
zwischen den Ländern und ihren Lenkern
Fließbandproduktion harmonischer Bilder
die zeigen sollen wir sind uns einig
beim Ausbau der Wirtschaftsbeziehungen
Zusammenarbeit in der Forschung
Austausch von Fachkräften der Kanzler
setzt den Ton betont optimistisch
wir haben bereits sehr gute Beziehungen
und wollen Sie jetzt noch weiter
intensiv ausbauen
Gemeinsamkeiten zu finden scheint unter
dieser Prämisse nicht schwer doch etwas
steht im Weg
indien hat Russland für seinen Krieg
nicht öffentlich verurteilt und das ist
ein Streitpunkt zwischen Indien und
Deutschland der Grund dafür indien will
den Gesprächsfaden zu Russland nicht
abreißen lassen denn Indien ist abhängig
von russischen Rüstungsgütern
55% aller indischen Waffen kommen aus
Russland für ein Land das sich von
vielen Seiten bedroht fühlt erscheint
das unverzichtbar Moskau liefert seit
Jahrzehnten was Indiens Armee begehrt
und erntet dafür jetzt offenbar Indiens
Neutralität
diplomatische Übung für Gast und
Gastgeber also unterschiedliche
Perspektiven so verpacken dass die
Stimmung nicht eintrübt
wir wissen dass dieser Krieg mit einem
Prinzip bricht auf das wir alle
gemeinsam uns lange verständigt haben
und dass wir miteinander teilen dass man
nämlich nicht mit Gewalt Grenzen
verschiebt seit Beginn der Entwicklungen
in der Ukraine hat Indien betonter
Streit durch Dialog und Diplomatie
gelöst werden müssen in denen steht
bereit um Friedensinitiativen zu
unterstützen
wegeebenen vielleicht das wichtigste
Ziel dieser Reise so habe man auch über
Rüstungsgeschäfte gesprochen deutsche
Waffentechnik für Indien um
Abhängigkeiten von Russland abzubauen
begleitet für uns die Reise warum es
Indien so wichtig geworden für
Deutschland
der Schlüsselwort hier lautet
zeitenwände der Kanzler geht ja davon
aus dass wir nach der Ukraine nach dem
Ukraine Krieg in eine multipolare Welt
gehen und das riesige indien ist ein
wichtiger Pol dabei und soll nebenbei
vielleicht auch helfen die deutsche
Abhängigkeit von China etwas zu
reduzieren man muss sich vor Augen
führen dass in wenigen Wochen Indien
China ablöst als das
bevölkerungsreichste Land der Welt dann
ist jeder fünfte Mensch auf dieser Erde
ein Inder oder eine Inderin der Kanzler
umwirbt Indien ganz besonders weil es
ein schwieriger Partner ist Indien hat
seit Jahrzehnten seine Rüstung aus
Russland bezogen und seitdem Sanktionen
durch den Ukraine Krieg hat es die Öl
Einfuhr für fünffach profitiert also im
Grunde von den Sanktionen die
Bundesregierung nimmt das einigerseits
billige in Kauf andererseits hat der
Kanzler heute klar gemacht dass er sich
schon eine klare Aussage von Indien
gewünscht hätte über die russische
Aggression aber alles sehr diplomatisch
denn man möchte Indien als stärkeren
Partner haben
aus einem sehr lebendigen neue Deli
danke schön für diese Einschätzung
eu-kommissionspräsidentin von der Leyen
sagt es seien insgesamt die
weitreichendsten Sanktionen aller Zeiten
die die EU-Staaten bislang beschlossen
haben gestern Abend noch das zehnte
Paket am Jahrestag des Kriegs in der
Ukraine die neuen Strafmaßnahmen sehen
unter anderem
Exportbeschränkungen im Wert von mehr
als 11 Milliarden Euro vor und betreffen
auch elektronische Bauteile für
Waffensysteme wie Drohnen oder Raketen
vor zwei Wochen veröffentlichten die
Frauenrechtlerin Alice Schwarzer und die
Linken Politikerin Sarah Wagenknecht ihr
umstrittenes Manifest für Frieden darin
fordern sie die Bundesregierung auf
statt auf Waffenlieferungen auf
Friedensverhandlungen zu setzen
mittlerweile haben mehr als
650.000 Menschen unterschrieben heute
hatten die beiden in Berlin zum Aufstand
für Frieden aufgerufen Markus groß
berichtet
friedensfahnen und antikriegslosungen am
Brandenburger Tor von 13.000 Teilnehmern
spricht die Polizei von weitaus mehr der
Veranstalter gekommen sind sie um gegen
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine und für
Verhandlungen zu demonstrieren ich habe
Kinder und ich möchte keinen Krieg die
Leute haben vergessen der Krieg ist noch
gar nicht so lange her und deshalb bin
ich hier
wir erreichen durch Verhandlungen die
Kundgebung umstritten Kritik vor allem
im Vorfeld weil eine klare Abgrenzung
gegen rechts fehlt für die Demo wurde
auch von rechten Gruppen getrommelt mit
Organisatoren Sarah Wagenknecht
relativiert
jeder der ehrlichen Herzens mit uns für
Frieden und für Verhandlungen
demonstrieren will ist hier willkommen
es ist der Versuch eine neue
Friedensbewegung zu etablieren Vorwürfe
in Richtung Bundesregierung
wir fühlen uns auch nicht vertreten von
einem Kanzler der zwar zunächst immer
zögert und für Bedachtsamkeit und
Vorsicht wirbt aber dann trotzdem
regelmäßig vor den kriegstrommlern in
seiner Koalition einknickt Kritik am
Aufruf der Veranstaltung von
spd-parteichefin esken die Forderungen
sein gefährlich wofür man es Verständnis
fehlt ist eben wenn man mit Rechtsaußen
mit russlandfahnen demonstrieren geht
mit anderen die diese Russland fahren
tragen denn das spielt nur einem in die
Hände Putin und seiner Propaganda das
ist eine neue Rechte querformt wie man
sie kennt anti-amerikanisch grundiert
und die letztlich nur eines will die
Waffen nieder damit wir Frieden haben
die Ukraine ist in ganz egal das Thema
polarisiert immer wieder auch kleine
Wortgefechte am Rande
die Kundgebung bleibt gehen friedlich
die Organisatoren hoffen auf einen
Startschuss für eine neue
Friedensbewegung umstritten bleibt sie
dennoch
bleiben wir in Berlin offenbar ist der
Abstand zwischen der SPD und den Grünen
bei der Wiederholungswahl noch knapper
als gedacht der Vorsprung der
Sozialdemokraten sei auf 53 Stimmen
geschmolzen meldet die BILD am SONNTAG
unter Berufung auf Unterlagen des
Landeswahlausschusses diese 53 Stimmen
könnten entscheidend sein bei der Frage
wer eine mögliche Koalition zwischen SPD
Grünen und Linken anführen könnte
gewonnen hatte die Wahl in Berlin die
CDU am Montag gibt es das endgültige
Wahlergebnis
es ist die größte Wahl in diesem Jahr in
Afrika Nigeria wählt einen neuen
Präsidenten und ein neues Parlament in
dem rohstoffreichen Land in Westafrika
leben etwa 220 Millionen Menschen
Tendenz stark steigend fast jeder zweite
kämpft gegen bittere Armut weit
verbreitet ist Korruption und es gibt
eine massive Bedrohung durch
islamistische Terroristen so ist allein
die Durchführung der Wahl alles andere
als selbstverständlich Susann von
Lojewski berichtet
er gilt für viele als Geheimfavorit
Peter obi-unternehmer 61 Jahre alt es
ist eine enorm wichtige Wahl das Land
geht durch eine sehr schwierige Zeit und
es braucht einen dringenden und
sofortigen Neuanfang
jeder vierte WLAN nigeria ist unter 34
Jahre gerade die jungen erhoffen sich
mit Obi einen echten Wandel
viele Menschen werden Peter Obi
unterstützen vernünftige Menschen die in
der Vergangenheit die größeren Parteien
gewählt haben die nur durch Gewalt
Einschüchterung und Autorität die Wahlen
gewonnen haben
das bevölkerungsreichste Land Afrika
steht vor enormen Herausforderungen vor
den Tankstellen seit Wochen
kilometerlange Staus Benzin ist knapp
zwar gibt es eigenes Erdöl das aber kann
im Land nicht raffiniert werden und wird
exportiert lange Schlangen auch vor den
Geldautomaten seit Ende Januar gibt es
neue Banknoten davon aber wurden viel zu
wenige gedruckt
meiner Mutter geht es nicht gut sie ist
im Krankenhaus ich war in drei
Bankautomaten und habe nur 5000 Naira
etwa 10 € bekommen ich kann das nicht
bezahlen
nigeria hat viele Rohstoffe eine
korrupte Elite aber hat das Land
heruntergewirtschaftet Terror und Gewalt
beherrschen viele aus den Alltag für
Korruption stehen auch volatilou und
Artico Abu Bakar auch sie haben Chancen
auf das Präsidentschaftsamt
sind so gigantisch das ist für welchen
Präsidenten auch immer wichtig ist die
Erwartungen zu managen
trotz aller Probleme sollten die Wahlen
friedlich verlaufen hätte das enorme
Symbolkraft für die gesamte Stabilität
im Westen Afrikas
auch zweieinhalb Wochen nach den
schweren Erdbeben im türkisch-syrischen
Grenzgebiet steigt die Zahl der Toten
weiter mehr als 50.000 sind es
inzwischen
allein in der Türkei sollen mehr als
173.000 Gebäude eingestürzt oder stark
beschädigt sein viele müssen gesprengt
oder abgerissen werden mittlerweile
wurden 184 Verdächtige festgenommen der
Vorwurf sie hätten Mindeststandards beim
Bau entweder nicht eingehalten oder
nicht ausreichend kontrolliert
in Deutschland rutschen immer mehr
Menschen in die Altersarmut vor allem
Frauen sind betroffen jeder dritten die
gerade in Vollzeit arbeitet droht eine
zu geringe Rente selbst nach 40
Arbeitsjahren das zeigen aktuelle Zahlen
der Bundesagentur für Arbeit warum das
so ist und was es heißt mit weniger als
1000 Euro im Monat auskommen zu müssen
zeigen Patrick müting und Sybille
theres nieder ist 82 Jahre alt sie
blickt auf ihr Leben zurück eine
frauenbiographie wie so viele mit 20
habe ich meine Kinder dazu von 30 bis 60
Jahre braucht davon bekommt sie heute
900 € Rente nach allen Abzügen bleibt
nicht viel übrig das ist so eng werden
würde hätte sie früher nicht gedacht
es rechts geht nicht man spart an alle
quandschuhe
irgendwo hingehen mit der Grundsicherung
schafft sie ist knapp hinzu kommt die
Unterstützung des Vereins ein Herz für
Rentner dieser hat auch die neue Dusche
finanziert über 3000 Menschen versorgt
der Verein in Köln und München mit dem
Nötigsten
die Scham kein Geld zu haben und und
gewissen sozialen Leben natürlich auch
nicht teilhaben zu können finde ich ganz
ganz traurig besonders Frauen sind
zunehmend von der Altersarmut bedroht
laut aktuellen Zahlen der Bundesagentur
für Arbeit erwartet jede dritte Frau die
zurzeit in Vollzeit arbeitet eine zu
geringe Rente die Gründe dafür die
geringere Löhne als Männer Frauen
arbeiten öfter in Teilzeit oder im
Minijobs die Kindererziehung
es braucht bessere Vereinbarkeit von
Familie und Beruf das ist ein wichtiger
Punkt und ganz entscheidend für uns ist
auch das zum Beispiel Zeiten der
Angehörigen Pflege viel besser
angerechnet werden für die Rente theres
niederhofft nur eines das nichts
Unvorhergesehenes dazwischen kommt in
einen finanziellen Puffer hat sie nicht
zehn Tage Berlinale gehen zu Ende
erstmals wieder ohne
corona-beschränkungen dafür mit
schillernden Hollywoodstars in einer
halben Stunde beginnt das große Finale
dann wird die internationale Jury
bekannt gegeben bekannt gegeben wen sie
mit dem goldenen und silbernen Bären
auszeichnet Stefanie Hein und Henriette
de Maiziere
einmal noch roter Teppich einmal noch
Blitzlicht für die Leute vom Film gleich
wird sich entscheiden wer mit einem
silbernen oder dem Goldenen Bären
ausgezeichnet wird fünf deutsche Filme
können sich Hoffnung machen einer davon
die zdf-co-produktion roter Himmel eine
Sommergeschichte vier Menschen ein Haus
an der Ostsee drumherum ein Waldbrand
mehr die Idee zum Film kam während des
corona-lockdowns als Reaktion auf die
vielen Einschränkungen besonders für
junge Menschen
ich muss jetzt was schreiben wo es um
Begehren Sommer Körper Liebe
aus diesem Gefühl heraus entstanden
der einzige Dokumentarfilm im Wettbewerb
hat beeindruckt er erzählt von einer
psychiatrischen Tagesklinik kommt den
Menschen sehr nah
keiner ist perfekt aber jeder Mensch hat
Ressourcen das zeigt der Film
soso Medi Protagonisten im japanischen
Anime-Film bringt mit ihrer Neugierde
erst die Welt durcheinander und muss sie
dann retten zauberhaft mit einem
dreibeinigen Stuhl in einer starken
Nebenrolle
der Stuhl ist eine Metapher für eine
unvollständige Seele ich wollte zeigen
dass Menschen auch nach einer großen
Verletzung und Verlust weiter leben und
leben können
ganz großes Kino eben in Berlin auf der
73 Berlinale
und jetzt ganz großes Kino im Sport ein
goldener Moment bei der Nordischen
Ski-WM ja theoretisch sind sogar vier
goldene Momente denn die deutschen
Skispringerinnen haben in Planitzer
Slowenien im Teamwettbewerb den WM-Titel
geholt Katharina Althaus Anna Ruprecht
Selina Freitag und Luisa Görlich
gewannen vor den Quartetts aus
Österreich und Norwegen
das Daumendrücken vor der letzten
Springerin hat sich gelohnt Katharina
Althaus behält die Nerven und landet bei
94,5 Metern das reicht um Deutschland
den Sieg und sich selbst nach dem Erfolg
im Einzel die zweite Goldmedaille bei
diesen Weltmeisterschaften zu sichern
danach gibt es für das deutsche Quartett
kein Halten mehr wir wissen ja dass sie
es kann und umso sehr haben wir uns
gefreut dass sie dann das wirklich so
geil runtergebracht hat und ja es war
einfach es hat einfach nur Spaß gemacht
für die deutschen Skispringerinnen ist
das nach dem Premieren Sieg 2019 der
zweite Titel im Team Wettbewerb
und im Einzel springen der Männer von
der Normalschanze hat Andreas Wellinger
soeben die Silbermedaille gewonnen
Riesenfreude im gesamten Team da die
Deutschen mit Karl Geiger auf Rang 3
gleich 2 Podestplätze erreichen
sensationell Gold für den Polen piotre
Schüler der mit Schanzenrekord von 105
Metern von Rang 13 auf Rang eins vor
fliegt ja und auch bei den Kombinierern
gab es in Planica eine Medaille fürs
deutsche Team durch Julian Schmidt im
ersten WM-Rennen seiner Karriere dann
gleich selber nach dem Springen auf der
Normalschanze lag der 23-Jährige auf
Platz 3 ja und in der Loipe lief er dann
nach vorne
besser nur der norwegische Titel
Verteidiger ja ja Magnus Riva aus
deutscher Sicht noch erfreulich Platz 54
Geiger und Manuel Feist
ja Wintersport natürlich heute abend
Thema im Aktuellen Sportstudio von 23
Uhr an neben der Fußball-Bundesliga und
es wird ein überaus zufriedener
bvb-sportdirektor zu Gast sein Sebastian
Kehl denn Borussia Dortmund springt nach
dem 9 Sieg im 9 Pflichtspiel des Jahres
an die Tabellenspitze hier die
Ergebnisse des 22 Spieltags ja Dortmund
gewinnt also und Hoffenheim 1:0 Leipzig
mit dem Heimsieg 2:1 gegen Frankfurt
Bremen schlägt Bochum 3:0 Wolfsburg kann
doch noch gewinnen nach zuletzt vier
sieglosen Spielen heute ein 2:0 Erfolg
in Köln und auch mit zwei Toren gewinnt
die Hertha gegen Augsburg das Abendspiel
Schalke Stuttgart ausführlich im
Aktuellen Sportstudio und bereits
gestern meins Gladbach 4 zu 0
in der Tabelle der BVB von morgen
allerdings noch das Spitzenspiel Bayern
gegen Union Berlin Leipzig auf vier
Freiburg kann aber morgen wieder vorbei
ziehen Frankfurt und Wolfsburg und
verändert auch Fragen 6 bzw 7 Bremen
jetzt auf 9 in der zweiten Hälfte
Gladbach ganz oben dahinter Leverkusen
Köln und Augsburg Hertha klettert von 17
auf 14 und im Tabellenkeller jetzt
Hoffenheim Bochum und Schalke
Punkt fertig danke der Sonntag bringt im
Nordwesten Sonne im Südosten weitere
Schneeschauer Details hat gleich Christa
Orban das heute journal um viertel nach
elf mit Dunja Hayali das gesamte heute
Team wünscht Ihnen noch ein schönes
Wochenende bis morgen wenn Sie mögen
tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend in die Mittelgebirge ist
noch einmal der Winter eingezogen auf
dem Fichtelberg im Erzgebirge liegt zum
Beispiel knapp 40 cm Schnee heute Abend
und auf dem Kahlen Asten im
Rothaargebirge knapp 20 cm Richtung
Osten da hat's heute auch bis ins
Flachland geschneit das bleibt hier
allerdings dann nicht so sehr liegen
heute Nacht kommt vor allem in den
stahllagen des Erzgebirges und der Alpen
noch mal um 10 cm Neuschnee zusammen bei
Schneeschauern ist es dann auch
verbreitet glatt im Westen klar ist auf
der frische Nordwind der in der Nacht
allerdings etwas abnimmt flutet uns aber
jetzt mit Polarluft und so wird diese
Nacht deutlich kühler als die vergangene
+ 2 Grad gibt es nur noch an der Nordsee
ansonsten frostig bis -8° an den Alpen
Bergland das ist dann noch morgen
tagsüber noch frostik im Nordwesten geht
hinauf auf plus 6 Grad das haben wir
hier der Sonne zu verdanken die sieben
bis neun Stunden scheint ganz anders
sieht es im Südosten aus bei nur 0 bis 4
Stunden Sonne hier gibt's dann aber auch
Schneeschauer die im Tagesverlauf dann
vor allem am am Alpenrand nachlassen im
Nordwesten scheint anfangs die Sonne
nachmittags kommen die Quellwolken der
Wind der kalte Nordwind frischt wieder
auf vor allem im Südwesten mit
stürmischen Böen und dann folgt in der
kommenden Woche eine trockenkühle Sonne
wolkenmischung mit frostigen Nächten
tschüss